mal angefangen 2015 mit der planung mit
der idee trachten waren sie ins leben zu
rufen habe dann 2016 in berlin auf der
fashion wie gleich am preis gewonnen mit
meiner ersten kollektion das war dann
der startschuss dann ging's los ein
bisserl aller tupper mit dem verkauf von
die handeln bei den weiblichen kunden
das hat sie dann weiterentwickelt dann
2017 war ich dann gern eigenen
gröbenzell schon bei jemandem mit dabei
da habe ich selber 80 quadratmeter
eigener kollektion sehr gut gelaufen
2018 dann den ersten großen laden in der
verdistraße eröffnet da mussten wir
leider wieder gehen weil die verdistraße
abgerissen wurde das warenhaus vom
kloster die amtsdauer appartements
darauf gebaut und so sind wir dann nach
wien gekommen
olching ist sensationell angelaufen also
es war für uns der hammer wohin sich
entwickelt hat
das gab uns dann die idee einen zweiten
laden zu machen um auch münchen und
richtung starnberg mit annan
kundenklientel zu gewinnen
da kam es dann eben dazu dass wir 2009
10 germering mit eröffnet haben im märz
eröffnet im ab ende juni gingen durch
die decke
wir hatten das beste wiesen geschäft
evers trachten wahnsinn gibt letztes
jahr 2019 dann kam die winterpause
dann erst im märz wieder aufgesperrt
erst im märz bis 8 märz 70 prozent
umsatz von monatsbudget erreicht und
dann kann da lockt dann und von da weg
ging es so was von steil nach unten
wir sind jetzt ungefähr bei acht bis
zehn prozent abverkauf vom letzten jahr
müssen jetzt leider zu sperren weil wir
es einfach nicht mehr hinbekommen
wir haben kredite laufen die muss ich
jetzt noch bedienen dafür habe jetzt
meine wohnung verkauft beziehungsweise
bin gerade dabei die wohnung zu
verkaufen
mein auto ist verkauft worden mein
motorrad ist verkauft worden
ich bin jetzt auch mit meiner
lebensgefährtin zusammen gezogen damit
alles irgendwie besser zu managen und zu
handeln ist weil ansonsten ist es
einfach nur machbar und wenn man heute
hoch sechsstelliger
geht mit - dann musst du einfach den
deckel drauf machen und dazu haben uns
jetzt entschlossen und gesundheitliche
soziale das ist ja auch nicht so ein
ganz gutes jahr
bei mir ist das große thema herz die
ganze psychische und körperliche
belastung hat es wieder verschlimmert so
dass sie jetzt am 5 oktober zuerst mein
herz op vor mir habe da kuriere ich mich
kann aus und dann schauen wir weiter wie
es weitergeht dann wird erst modeladen
geräumt und dann muss sie erst einmal
wieder bisserl zu mir finden um dann
leben neu zu starten 2021 dj ist kann
man sagen wie auch mit trachten also es
war hat das ganze jahr überhaupt nichts
insgesamt waren zwei hochzeiten da die
die ich machen dürfte ansonsten alle
feiern von schule abschlussbälle über
hochzeiten über clubs wo auflegt alles
zu alles weggebrochen nichts mehr mein
sohn ist die geschichte keine kurz
erzählen also ich habe letztlich erst
mit meinem sohn über das thema
gesprochen dass wir jetzt zu sperren und
mein sohn hat mich dann ermutigt und mir
mitgeteilt dass also das
weihnachtsgeschenk dieses jahr da sie
das lassen darf ich muss ihm nichts zu
weihnachten schenken damit sich alle
sparen kann damit mit mir weitergeht und
wir sind dann halt einfach so berührende
momente ein 13-jähriger so was zu einem
sagte er vom playstation spielen oder
alles nicht genug bekommt aber sagt papi
dies ist ja lass einfach
vielen dank
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren